ein eishockey fan geht zu einem spiel
und rettet dem zeug war des gegnerischen
teams das leben per handy wir haben uns
von der helden im interview die ganze
geschichte mal klären lassen
riesenüberraschung für eine
lebensretterin eishockeyfan nadia
popovic bekommt gerade im stadion einen
10.000 dollar zuschuss für ihr
medizinstudium und sie hat sich auch
jeden cent davon verdient denn sie
bewahrte den zeugwart der vancouver
canucks vor dem krebstod
die unglaubliche geschichte startete im
oktober letzten jahres beim spiel der
seattle kraken gegen die vancouver
canucks sind die junge medizinstudentin
direkt hinter der knacks ersatzbank
beste sicht auf das spiel und den hals
von zeugwart brian hamilton
sein kragen verrutschte und ich sah
einen leberfleck der besorgnis erregend
aus st farblos große haben und mit
unregelmäßigen rand ich dachte er müsste
damit unbedingt mal zum arzt
doch wie kommuniziert man in einer
grölenden arena nadja schnappt sich ihr
handy und tippt eine nachricht der
leberfleck an der rückseite ihres hauses
ist möglicherweise krebs bitte gehen sie
zu einem arzt
ich klopfe an die scheibe mit der
nachricht auf dem handy ihr lasst sie
rückte erstmal mit den schultern und
gehen
doch der hinweis lässt hamilton nicht
kalt er lässt den fleck untersuchen und
tatsächlich er erweist sich als
schwarzer hautkrebs der bösartige tumor
wird sofort entfernt
der doktor sagte hätte ich dass die
nächsten jahre ignoriert werde ich bald
nicht mehr hier
doch wie kann zeugwart nun seiner
lebensretterin danken klar er pustet auf
der twitter seite der canucks einen
suchaufruf mit erfolg der aufruf geht
viral ja meine ma rief mich an schaue
auf die twitter-seite des teams da sehe
ich dass jeder nach ihr sucht
als brian und nadja endlich
aufeinandertreffen gibt es wird glück
eine mächtige umarmung und ein riesiges
dankeschön die beiden nhl teams haben
zusammengelegt um nadja einen teil ihres
medizinstudiums zu finanzieren so kann
sie in zukunft noch viel mehr
menschenleben retten
[Applaus]